oh yeah and another game they guy that I
guess came out this month that might be
good I don't know is uncharted for today
it's out to day well it can buy right
now why are you watching this
download it a free download of that last
night yeah
had a little ticker saying it'll be
unlock in 15 minutes then had to go play
tennis for an hour sucks I wanted to
play Uncharted Michael Hardy you've
played a lot of time it I have some
complaints with it but its overall it's
work originally you play a lot of
uncharted you were awarded at a 10 and a
10 on yes but I've actually lost can of
team at a tenant of depends we've given
12 12 now there was the time work was
there until I was only like seven about
yeah you were going yeah and then Metal
Gear Solid The Witcher 3 and journey who
got them last year I'm trying to afford
the best Uncharted game yeah definitely
no it's not China 2 is really good it's
not as groundbreaking as uncharted 2 but
it is better okay because don't try to
came along and blew our faces off what's
happening and now games can do this yeah
and now uncharted 4 is saying well
really this is what we can do okay it's
just not as much of a surprise right
it's it's awesome it's in so many
different aspects and it's not all it's
not just how the individual quality of
it like the combat the storytelling the
writing the animation just how it looks
it's how they all kind of combine to
form something that uses all of its
aspects to tell a story that you
couldn't really tell the same way in any
other medium so explain I guess sort of
the nuts and bolts of that like what are
the things in this game which feel you
know if not groundbreaking then better
than anyone else has done within this
genre and on charter for sure so you
watch a cutscene and the animations the
first off the facial animations and
animations in general are pretty much
there it's it's the like the way that it
can express like just distrust something
that you couldn't write C on a videogame
characters face most of the time it the
way they do that is pretty great and how
the writing flows into that but also
when you're just fighting they'll be
these incidental little things that they
do like the Uncharted has always done
this but there's even there's points
where like certain relationships will
start to change the dynamics will change
and like
the way they address each other when you
just walk by them when you're playing
will actually kind of react to that and
you at first I was like I think I'm
looking too much into this but then they
kind of addressed that later like oh
they meant that and there's so many ways
that they use the world itself to tell a
story the Rob point something out to me
and something happened on the time I'm
trying to bury hide not spoil yeah but
it sounds like I'm jealous because yeah
being general so something happens with
these characters and then Rob noticed
something in the world the landscape
itself that with like look differently
which is pretty crazy that they did that
but I don't know Jake and I both beaten
it and I know you're playing right now
and it also it flows so well it I love
the intimate personal moments between
characters just as much as the crazy
action car chases through medic ass car
it's the way that they flow into one
another and kind of maintain the
momentum even when you're not fighting
and you're just kind of driving through
this countryside and hearing these two
characters talk yeah it's it's such a
great way to tell a story in so many
different ways and it's it's really the
momentum doesn't let up the whole time I
mean you know Naughty Dog are a long way
from crash bandicoot in this game just
when you think about it in like a post
Last of Us world like they really are
just incredible at making stories and
I've only played the first two chapters
which I think were maybe an hour and a
half maybe long or something total and
like I put the controller down to hop on
the bus to come to work and was just
like god dammit this is so brilliant I'm
just enjoying every minute of it Jake
what's been your experience playing and
where does this sit in terms of the rest
of you and charters like have you have
you experienced all those other games as
well and does this feel special yeah so
I've played all the Uncharted Uncharted
games and this one's definitely my
favorite I pretty much agree with what
Mike said I think the way it tells the
story has just been so fine-tuned the
way Naughty Dog does it has they've
basically perfected at least the sort of
storytelling they're trying to go for
you know how gameplay cuts in gameplay
cutscene but like their parts when you
can't even tell which is crazy I
remember like when uncharted 2 came out
Sony did that promotion like like you
can't tell if you're playing a game or
watching a movie or whatever and this
actually feels like that and the one
scene in Madagascar that he kind of
mentioned a second we saw at e3 like
that's all game play right yeah and like
you know you see it at e3 and you're
like yeah okay let's see if it actually
it's gonna look like that and then you
play through it and you're like oh my
god I am actually controlling this and
it's it's breathtaking I
taken aback because I in like the past
couple of months I've become a little
bit of a PC snob again because I've
graded my rig and I'm like really
enjoying games whereas like all last
year I basically just played games on
Xbox one and PlayStation 4 and and I
gotta say when I was about maybe five
minutes into this game or a PlayStation
4 sounded like it was about to take off
but she didn't matter because I was I
had the volume are pretty high but there
are times I'm playing this game I'm like
man this is running on a goddamn
PlayStation 4 like there's something
about a naughty dog they've always
managed to like crank the most out of
the PlayStation I don't know what it is
it looks incredible yeah it's weird
runs incredible oh yeah definitely great
animation the vistas themselves it's not
like they're doing one of them really
well like so many other games those like
across the board it just looks
tremendous yeah I mean the 30 frames in
campaign the 60 and multiplayer both
like I don't think I saw Sutter the
entire campaign of the bunch of hours I
put into multiplayer I didn't see any
problems the way that they actually like
Rob handler II well a bunch of us have
been doing it using the photo mode in
the game Ryan which it's telling of how
a game looks that you actually are
encouraged to you want to use that
otherwise what would be just like a
bonus aspect didn't they put that in
left behind wasn't this in the right it
was in the ps4 they brought it it was on
The Last of Us right behind ya and it
we've been taking photos in there a
couple there's one Rob got of this old
hallway and at the end there's this
there's this window open and it's
shining light on these puddles this
dilapidated place and it looks
photorealistic it's it's crazy like how
the lighting plays off of certain areas
and how you'd like especially in the
cutscenes the characters faces just it's
the way like there's one scene Jake and
I always talk about and you can read it
differently that's like it's a very well
written story and you can kind of look
at certain characters what they say and
how they mean it at one point a
character says like we've got a lot of
ground to cover and you're kind of
thinking oh well they just mean like the
geographically but then but then you
kind of start thinking about it like oh
or they could just like be sort of on
the way to it's like they're talking
about their relationship kind of like
there's a bunch of different dynamics
going on and the way that the facial
animations and how it looks during the
cutscenes in and out that they actually
just kind of push that story without
even using words it's it's insane yeah I
guess I have a very selfish question how
long is it because I've been only thing
a couple of hours but I already know
that I don't want this to end
what what are we clocking in took me I
think my total save time was like 13 45
about 14 hours or so yeah
all right self check mine was probably
out the same I think maybe 12 hours I
did in two sittings yeah I mean you got
a you know all that time playing The
Witcher he's gotta cram it in there so
you have completely three again but yeah
I think - probably maybe the first the
first third of the games they're 22
chapters and then a fairly lengthy
epilogue right there are the first third
of the game is kind of slow and it's it
a good slow and it's pacing but then
that's when it feels like an in charter
game and then after that and I hear to
see like Peter Brown sat down one
sitting got to chapter 11
rice in chapters halfway but it starts
to get a little longer because another
thing that this game does definitely is
structurally it opens up a lot of its
level design there where we saw the Jeep
sort of so sure I think they're about
three areas where it's really open and
you're driving through and exploring and
then there are these it's almost like
Metal Gear Solid 5 not as not just like
directly focused on stealth and combat
smell yourself right there are these
outposts you can sneak into tall grass
climb on ledges mark people and then you
can even just go through you can avoid
them you can just you don't even have to
engage in combat and which feeds more
into this story because the story is
very much of trach kind of coming to
grips to the fact that he's not a good
person the first three games
yeah and they address that Brioni oh
that's nice it's it's okay because
that's been the elephant in the room
forever with the names because they
crafted these incredibly believable
characters but still have them in a
place where they're mowing down hundreds
of people I mean you're still fighting
this game you will kill people at
certain points be it's it's a
third-person shooter but the gameplay
itself not only that's what's crazy
about it you know like Josh air and Neil
druckmann who wrote this have somehow
found a way to address the problems the
first three games this writing whether
you think their problems or not which I
always when I returned to the collection
last year it felt weirder like they have
such a sense of humor and they kind of
after they killed much people but now
they actually kind of addressed Drake's
psyche and that this is how he uses his
humor as a shield this is how like he's
would grow he's been a loner and most of
his life and he it kind of that's why he
doesn't open up well and a lot of it he
don't hide home for me and maybe for you
um I know this is such a like stretch
but I remember like when Roger Ebert was
writing about Martin Scorsese he
always say like his growing up Catholic
plays a lot more into hit than work than
it does and they kind of see that here
and that hit home for me I grew up
Catholic and you kind of see how that
shaped him as a kid I mean immediately
the first couple of hours was yes and
like you get he gets old Ernie stops
like believing in like that's that kind
of religion but now he but he believes
in this like the Eldorado exists so like
it's like it's him replacing what he
used to believe in with these new things
and they kind of addressed how he has
his characters developed the entire
series and you know the big driving
thing is um Adam that right um yeah I'm
getting toward spoilers that's that's
play the game because I wanna and then
we're doing it yeah reporting smaller
cast later and I can't wait to get into
because this is the this is the kind of
game where you can I you know like not
to sound like a pompous jerk but you can
really analyze the stuff and look at it
like look deeper at it because but not
just in its writing in like its gameplay
and how that factors into it and how
certain characters interact in the game
and how like certain visuals look and
how certain shots are framed it's it's
it's really really good awesome but at
the same time it's just the pacing is so
great that it's it's the game as fun as
hell like in no way do I want to make it
sound like it's just this like artistic
kind of thing it's uncharted your book
you're gonna blow things up it's you got
a grappling hook this time around
it makes battles feel really fun you can
sneak past people without fighting if
you want it gives you more choices on
how to play you can explore this time
around it's uncharted you're gonna be
like globe-trotting in these really cool
places yeah play this game exciting
stuff play this game you heard us you're
first I'm very fascinated by that idea
of like solving the bioshock infinite
problem oh yeah or like diving into like
this respect off the line type of
narrative storytelling results that's
super fascinating yeah thank you both
for coming in and talking to us about
uncharted 4 a thief's end available now
on your PlayStation 4 not said sorry PC
and Xbox one owners maybe this is worth
picking up a ps4 though yeah